están muy cerca de ellos eso es lo que
asegura la Fuerza Armada colombiana
sobre los cuatro niños perdidos en el
departamento del guaviare su sustento
una nueva huella que se supone
corresponde a una de las menores Un
refugio improvisado y restos de frutas
mordidas encontradas el domingo
sin duda alguna nos genera una nueva
iniciativa nos genera una nueva emoción
encontrar una huella de una menor de
edad para lo cual en el terreno de los
soldados colocan una huella de ellos
talla 40 junto a la huella de la menor
para evidenciar y poder tener el claro
el tamaño de la misma y ha arrojado
Esperanza sobre encontrar a los hermanos
de 13 9 4 y un años que sobrevivieron a
un accidente de avioneta en el que murió
su madre el 1 de Mayo en plena selva las
autoridades pudieron recuperar los
cuerpos de los tres adultos pero el
paradero y el estado de los niños son
todo un misterio desde entonces un
equipo de 160 militares y indígenas
intentan andar con ellos entre los
departamentos del guaviare y caquetá
desde el inicio de la búsqueda los
rescatistas han recorrido mil doscientos
cincuenta kilómetros pero ahora la
búsqueda se ha reducido a un área de 30
km las hipótesis de que los menores
estén con las disidencias de las FARC
presentes en la zona o con indígenas no
contactados han sido descartadas no
obstante en la zona hay depredadores
como Jaguares y serpientes y llueve una
media de 16 horas al día